star Trak how exciting to have
representatives from all for sirs we're
double dipping with Michael Dorn Abed
because he's been in next generation and
deep space 9 but to be up here with
these fine folks it really makes me want
to take America and get us to the place
that Gene Roddenberry imagined for the
future and these folks are the faces of
the future they represented a future for
all of us that we've seen for 50 years
in Star Trek and Star Trek storytelling
one of the things that I love about Star
Trek is the mythology and the mythology
building it's such an intricate web that
Gene Roddenberry created that it's very
exciting for me to ask William Shatner
how important is Star Trek Canon how
important is the mythology to you the
Canon when you load it with a ball you
put up the Canon
you mean all the things that we have
heard that Star Trek does
non-interference that kind yes how
important is it it's essential it is the
basis of law and order it's the basis of
civilization it is so in Canon if we
were to undo Kirk's death I'm just
asking for scientific purposes if we
were to undo Kirk's death undo Kirk's
death if it didn't happen say in a
magical world and it didn't happen yes
wouldn't it be wonderful to continue
telling stories about Captain Kirk with
you in that role
hell yes you heard it from the man hell
yes so Brent one of the the greatest
episodes and the earliest episodes of
the next generation was measure of a man
it was all about human and individual
rights and identity is such a fantastic
aspect of datas character and we're in a
place now in the country where identity
is under attack where were individual
rights are under attack what do you
think Lieutenant Commander data would
feel about where we are now and how can
we get to where we need to go well I
think first could you just build to stop
looking at me absolutely Brian it's a
it's a it's such a big subject I I
really wish I could
can you all leave and I can just yeah no
but I think Star Trek in general has
been about individual rights and has
been about you yes me know about
respecting everyone no matter who or
what they are and we're living in a
world right now where that sort of
respect is is being challenged not just
all over the world but in our country
too and it's disturbing and I think a
lot of our politicians and a lot of our
fellow citizens could take a page from
Star Trek at this point and have a bit
more respect for humanity for all of us
Jarry as a seventh of nine you struggled
with with your own identity and identity
issues and and issues of individualism
anything you'd like to add to that I
agree with everything you just said but
I think I will say one thing for the
Borg villains though they may be they
absolutely respected every species and I
mean you know assimilated and took the
best of aspect of every species but they
certainly weren't exclusionary or not
and you know 7 was put in a unique
situation a unique position because her
personal choice and rights were taken
away from her not once but twice they
were taken away when she was assimilated
by the Borg as a child and then they
were taken away again by Captain Janeway
when she was forcibly separated from the
Borg which was another decision that was
made for her that she didn't choose so I
think seven sort of experienced that and
and and struggled with that on a very
personal level individuality is very
important for all of us and it must be
celebrated whenever we can celebrate it
Michael boy you've done a lot of Star
Trek a lot of wonderful Star Trek and
one of the wonderful things about the
original series is seeing a bridge crew
that united so many different types of
people on the enterprise with the next
generation we had seen Worf as a Klingon
introduced to a Starfleet bridge he was
the first of his kind Star Trek is about
celebrating diversity it's infinite
diversity in infinite combinations how
does it feel to be the first Klingon in
Starfleet and what can you say about the
importance of diversity in our teams
that we build today well you know it was
it was an honor because I was a fan of
the original show and I am
you know my brother and I washed and we
loved the Klingons and we thought that
you know great characters and I thought
that I didn't really put that much
thought into what it meant but I did
know that the thought that Gene
Roddenberry had was that he wanted to
show that we have moved on that the
characters have evolved that things are
different they're not the way it the way
it was before and part of that is is
part of our country you know I mean at
the time before that the you know the
Berlin Wall came down and the Russians
weren't our enemies anymore and people
were caught by surprise and so I thought
that along with you know being a great
character that I was I was handed was
that he represented what this starship
you know you're going on space and we
all respect each other but there's a lot
of guys that don't like Klingon still
and so there are still that bit of well
we accept all races except the Klingons
you know and so it gave everybody I'd
like to think it gave everybody a chance
to for the character to look at the
start the the crew and the crew to look
at him and become very close as they did
over the years which was which was
really great I mean they learned a lot
about each other and is one of the
wonderful things about playing the
character from next generation and deep
space was that thing the guy could grow
and he really changed over here
especially in deep space he really
became a more than a two-dimensional and
three-dimensional character so it was it
was fantastic and the heritage and the
culture of the Klingons was fascinating
so much today we're afraid of people who
were so different than us and it feels
like a great statement that Gene
Roddenberry was always trying to make
with how we need first and foremost to
get along as a species well you know it
interestingly enough the at from the
original series the guys were just kind
of wild and running around like crazy
and with the undiscovered country
which really showed them in a very
Shakespearean way I mean they quoted
Shakespeare and they were very eloquent
and the thing with with people ask me
all the time is that you know did you
have a lot to do with the writing and I
said not at all I mean I originated the
character but the writers took it off
into this to this world where the the
Klingons were this rich culture that we
thought were one's one-dimensional just
wanted to kill just wanted to conquer
and they're not and that is a good
lesson for for our times I mean we look
at people from different worlds from a
window of one dimension you know and if
you go in there I love this this line
from staying where he says you know the
Russians love their kids as much as we
do and that is really important I mean
these are if you have a chance you
people are just not one-dimensional well
you said something very interesting
because I remember the episode where
Picard was being tortured by the
Kardashians and the Kardashians said
about humans they don't love their
children like we love our children and
it's so easy to alienate something that
is different than us and it's something
it's a trap that we all fall into and
it's a Star Trek is a a warning to us
about how we can be one and that's the
most beautiful message of Star Trek
Captain Archer mr. Scott Bakula the
first in the timeline to captain the
enterprise and we know that starships
are not built with cynicism they're not
built with fear-based hate they're built
with science and one of the most
beautiful things about science is that
scientists know they have to collaborate
scientists know they know everything
about what they know and they know that
others know everything about what they
know and only working together can they
find a better future how does it feel to
be the first captain of the enterprise
and know
where we are now and where we need to go
oh that's an easy one I'm still stuck on
tortured by the Kardashians look I being
the first captain that's what sold me on
being in this franchise and being a part
of this world when it was pitched to me
that way because I knew that I could
never follow all of these folks and all
of the other captains so it was a it was
an out for me to be first because I
could just say well I can't do anything
wrong because bill won't know what I'm
doing
but science fiction has always
fascinated me because of not just the
science but the nature of the optimism
that goes with the science so you take
the science and the fiction and you
create this optimism that somehow we're
gonna figure it out that somehow we're
going to continue on that somehow we'll
be here in the future that somehow will
take care of our planet that somehow
we'll realize that there aren't borders
that we're all one unit unified species
regardless of religion and color and all
the other things that we have thrown up
in the middle of us and take care of
each other and take care of the place we
live on and this planet and so I just I
tend to be an optimistic person in real
life and I have been and continue to be
hopeful and and positive that somehow
even when it's dark and some things are
presented to us that seem completely
impossible that we as a species will
figure it out the scientists help us and
the dreamers help us and what we do in
our world and in our as actors and and
what you do in your lives helps all of
us and that's that's the that's the joy
of getting to be an actor and then
getting to be in a place like this which
is on
believable to be here today 50 years 51
years after that guy at the end of the
table started it all thank you and and
and yet and yet science fiction
some of it is optimism some of it says
250 years from now I will have through
technology will have figured it out
and yet the time is coming the time has
come to figure it out its approaching
the late hour I had an interesting talk
with David Suzuki yesterday I was in
Vancouver on a show David Suzuki's world
renowned ecologist and the question I
was asking him was is it too late as the
tipping point been reached and this is
what he said yes it's possible that it's
now too late to save a large part of
humanity but last year on the Fraser
River in British Columbia which is the
the river that carries the most salmon
in the world was down to one twentieth
of the salmon run from when it was at
its height and he said to his wife David
said has it happened is this now the end
of the salmon does that mean the whole
northwest of of our country America a
Canada and America is coming to an end
because the salmon are a primary force
and renewing life there and it was
possible he went to bed he said that
night when he learned that news a year
later the salmon run was twenty times
what it was
1 million and became 20 million the next
year nobody knows why nobody knows how
and instead of losing hope that salmon
run suggested that there are mysteries
and things in nature that will surprise
us but that doesn't let us off the hook
we need to act and act fast well said
sir Jerry when you were playing seven of
nine there was always a question of
whether you assimilate into the crew or
your let your freak flag fly as a board
and right now there's so many things
happening that we all could use a little
height in our freak flag agree that's
how we're gonna find each other the
freaks have to unite because the freaks
are who are going to save the planet
and we're all freaks here so let's wait
a flag
you